well it is so good to be back on the
program to talk about such important
issues today as the popping of balloons
Alpha Joe Biden has popped the Chinese
balloon and trumpists are Furious why
are they Furious well it's not even
clear that they know
oh boy I I want to make clear that for
me this story is really about the meta
narrative in other words
there is a hilarious story here that has
developed and it is the story being told
about the story being told about this
Chinese surveillance balloon and so
we're not really talking about the
balloon per se
but we're talking about the narrative
about The Narrative of the balloon and
the story in reality is not really about
Joe Biden or Donald Trump but there is
something so funny about right Wingers
spending a couple of days saying weak
beta Joe Biden isn't going to do
anything about the balloon Biden orders
the balloon blown up and then we found
out that similar balloons maybe the same
balloon actually crossed over U.S
territory three times when Donald Trump
was president now that being said I'm
not going to
tell you anything we don't believe to be
true it seems right now that Trump was
not actually told about that now this is
the subject of some controversy and
we're going to talk about it but it
seems as though the latest claims are
the Trump Administration or Trump
specifically was not actually told about
this during his administration and so we
will get to that the Associated Press
has a worthwhile article if you want to
get caught up on this balloon bickering
over Biden's actions in China's
intentions the article reads Republican
lawmakers Sunday accused China of
deliberately surveilling sensitive U.S
military sites with a suspected spy
balloon and said the Biden
administration had given Beijing an
intelligence opening by not Downing the
balloon during its high altitude drift
during American airspace Now understand
that if you down the balloon while it is
over U.S land it's extraordinarily
dangerous and so there was a decision
made to wait until it was over water and
that is when the balloon was popped and
this is actually what we are talking
about here China meanwhile accused the
U.S of indiscriminate use of force when
the American Military shot it down the
vice foreign minister said he lodged a
formal complaint with the U.S embassy
very very aggressive they are not happy
about it
um then there is an article from the uh
from Business Insider Republicans are
blaming Biden for letting a suspected
Chinese spy balloon cross into the U.S
it happened three times during the Trump
Administration officials say would Trump
have let China fly a spy balloon over
our country tweeted Jim Jordan
Chinese spyballoons were cited three
times during the Trump Administration
now I tweeted yesterday
um that the story was there's a Chinese
balloon over U.S airspace Maga says
Biden won't blow it up Biden blows it up
Magus says big deal any president would
have blown it up and then we learned
actually it flew over U.S airspace three
times under Trump and Trump didn't blow
it up it is believed right now it is
believed right now that the Chinese spy
balloons that flew over U.S airspace in
U.S airspace under Trump were not
discovered until Trump was no longer in
office and if that's the case my tweet
yesterday was based on the information
we had then and we've since learned more
so you don't need to include that to
realize the absurdity of the story about
the story the story about the story is
Trump tough on China
Biden weak on China that's the that's
the the The Meta narrative that exists
here
in reality what we have is Biden
immediately went to military advisors
was told we can pop it but it could
actually hurt people if we did it while
it was over land so if you give the
order sir you can give the order for us
to pop it when it's not over land over
water took a couple of days for it to
reach that position and then it was
indeed popped Trump did not do anything
like that about these balloons our best
information now is that Trump didn't
have that opportunity and that's
perfectly fine but the story of Biden
very very weak on China
Trump very very strong on China
continues to fall apart and something
about this balloon story has massively
triggered Donald Trump let's see if we
can figure out what it is
did you know that half of Americans are
deficient in vitamin A vitamin C and
magnesium most Americans are deficient
in vitamin D I take vitamin D during the
winter it is sometimes difficult to eat
exactly the right amount of each food to
get exactly what you need I just make my
life simpler with ag1 by athletic Greens
in the morning one scoop of ag1 I get
the entire day's worth of 75 high
quality vitamins minerals and Whole Food
sourced ingredients it's what I want
it's no more it's no less it's not
making any outlandish claims it's just
an easy sustainable routine I've tried
different ways of taking vitamins ag1 is
cheaper it's quicker it's tastier I'm
not fumbling around with different
capsules it tastes great to drink
straight with water sometimes I'll put
it in a smoothie or Shake it's simple
it's something easy you can do going
into the new year staying properly
nourished athletic greens is giving my
audience a free year supply of vitamin D
I take that every day in Winter plus
you'll get five free travel packs of ag1
go to athleticgreens.com
Pacman the link is down below